well
it's time for dear drew we appreciate a
good handwritten letter and it warms our
heart that you take the time
to put pen to paper and add your
personal touches
let's start with celebrating our zip
code of the day
44114 in cleveland ohio
i know home of the local cbs affiliate
the cw cw-43 cleveland
first indoor shopping mall the arcade
in cleveland opened in 1890.
i wonder what the retail was like
cleveland didn't invent
rock music but a local dj coined the
term
rock and roll in the 1950s i know
it's so cool cleveland ohio we would
love to hear from you
i want to hear from you so send me some
mail if you'd like
all right let's get into our first
letter
dear drew i am too a big fan of snail
mail
i snared my first serious boyfriend via
the usps and some clever flirting
he was homesick and i leaned into it
hard
he was a good writer and he made me
laugh anywho i became a writer too so my
question
is what's the best love letter you've
ever received
amanda falls church virginia
gosh i don't remember a letter
that i got but i know i won't i wrote
one and i got the guy back
for sure yeah and i it's of course i did
like
it was so good i sent it i was like you
are gonna be so
questioning that you left and he came
back
with flowers and uh and then we broke up
so that was great um but the letter
worked
so anyway okay let's get to our next
letter
number two brandie reed from kansas city
kansas
oh this one's got oh pictures
oh oh yes brandi
whoever you are i am feeling you
okay oh wow look at this uh-huh
uh-huh let's see uh-huh
oh oh hello that's me on a sunday
okay let's see randy who are you hi
meow my name is sly
james the cat oh this is from a cat
i'm a tabby bengal mix who's four years
old
i like celebrating holidays so my mom
started making costumes for me to
celebrate a holiday every day
we use our platform on instagram sly
james
the cat to promote social causes
make people happy and bring joy to a
sometimes dark world
randy kansas city kansas okay at sly
james the cat
i am i need you i love you i'm going to
immediately start following you we're
going to throw it up on the website
and thank you so much i can't wait to
just brag about you to everybody keep up
the good work
thank you brandi at sly
james okay and our third letter is
[Applause]
ten-year-old shayna from woodcliff lake
new jersey
oh sheena i like you already
i'm biased for youngren's okay
dear drew recently i started my own
business making face mask chains
they are really useful to have so that
you don't lose your mask and you don't
have to put it down on a germ-covered
surface
i'm going to make my first 500 donation
to valley hospital
in ridgewood new jersey and i was hoping
you could match it and
encourage other kids to help their local
hospitals
p.s i hope you like the chain sorry i
didn't have any flower beads i know you
love flowers
shayna woodcliff new jersey okay first
of all i also happen to love
rainbows so shayna i think you're
perfect
oh my name is on there too which is
great because then i don't have to be
like that's mine
[Music]
um okay this i'm going to put it on
right now
and shayna i am going to
match your 500 donation and i'm going to
add an extra thousand
so that's two thousand dollars
i'm so proud i'm so impressed and as a
mother of two girls
wow okay so if anyone out there needs
any advice
help maybe you want to see me try
something mail me your questions
requests
photos heartfelt funny stories i don't
know i just can't wait to read more of
your letters
live on the show so amanda brandie with
sly the cat and shayna
thank you for my letters here are my
postcards to you
all right truly yours drew